hi there
today i'd like to talk and this will
more likely be in two parts it's
this uh thought that i'm having at the
moment
i'm getting a lot of feedback from uh
various medias and
uh most people enjoying it but the talks
but uh some are obviously telling me
don't go there tony don't upset things
best not to say this and
that world i don't fit into i've never
fitted into it
i think if you don't have
self-expression
as long as you're big enough to take
what you're going to say
and of course criticism hurts
but i think you should be big enough to
be able to
take it let it affect you think about
it and decide if you want to keep that
um thought in your head or whether you
want to be like what i call the rest of
the sheep in the world
and just follow along happily not
wishing to disturb anything
or say anything that is out of place
people like me are
very much individual as far as we
become learners we have a purpose and
our purpose is to make you think
think about what you're doing
whether you can take the criticism or
not or whether your
spirit inside of you has a flame big
enough to burn that you
you have to say what you you truly
believe
in hopes that people's own
thoughts will not get fogged and just
become another sheep in the back
i use this word a lot
about following being a sheep and
following
because when you see them just going
along going along down
one will jump over a wall or one will go
through a hole in the fence
not many will follow them and then
they'll finally come back on track
most of them are just going along
where the others are perhaps that's a
simpler life
but it's not one for me
if we forget the competition of
my aikido is better than yours
i'm mainly talking about iwama versus
kai but
really it's the hong dojo where the
softer more flying aikido was developed
and it was developed by kishimura the
ishiba
who's sent his son who
really i think as a business took it
to her to the levels that it is today
all over the world and i'd like to just
think about this rather than me
saying about the different styles the
softness
because there's yoshinkan tamiki
iwama honbu
i am a sick ranked six-day nike guy
and so that's a certification system
that comes from the hong kong hong kong
being recognized
as the main world headquarters
i'd like to talk more about the the
styles
in in other films later on
and the development but i'd like today
to talk about
if i'm talking to another business
person if you're at the end of this as a
business person
what would your thoughts be i
sense he had a product but he had a
product in a small way
he used to go once a month and teach it
in
tokyo for the homo dojo
but his son didn't think that that would
work that wouldn't work with the people
in tokyo so that means
it wouldn't work in large cities
and yet large cities is where the money
can be made
if you're looking at it's a monetary
system
how about if we change it so it is more
adaptable to the people that we're
selling the idea to
and what we'll do is we'll we'll send
our reps out
into the world into some prime locations
and we'll get them set up there
and we'll get them teaching the style
that is more suitable to the
academics the yes
we may get the people come along who are
more manual
but in general we're selling to the the
large vast numbers
and that way we will get more money come
back in
through giving out certification of
black belts
they're very expensive you know when you
see a
showdown a minimum cost of 200 dollars
it varies throughout the world it
appears everybody seems to have a
different price
and yet the teachers to my knowledge
that
do the testing don't really get the
money
it normally goes back to the
headquarters in tokyo
i'm not trying to knock them i'm just
putting this as an idea
if i was a businessman talking to
another businessman
or woman come to that sorry to be sexist
so what we'll do is we'll make the style
so
it's active you get fitness and
well-being
it is a martial art so there'll be moves
in it
that can be done to protect yourself but
the main thing is for it to look good
and to keep people fit and healthy
so we've got the locations worked out we
have to quickly bring up
our representatives to a good enough
standard that we can send them out
and hopefully with their own practice
they will improve
and yes they did they went out to the
world but they all went out as
individuals
with a style of aikido that came from
the hombu dojo
they may have spent some time in iwama
under o'sensei
and cytoscenci because cytosexy being
the
the head of the hiwama dojo
while they're sensitive alive and he
used to go on sundays with osensi to
teach
in the hong ko dojo and why the
weapons i was told by cytosense he's not
seen um in a large way by the
honbu style is that osensi
um said to cytosexy
my son has already ruined and destroyed
the aikido that i perform in iwama
please don't teach them the weapons
so they cannot destroy them how true is
i can only take such a sense his word
for it
but we don't see the iwama style weapons
that we know as basic suburbs and
carters
taught by the honbu they mainly teach
kashima bokken
or the individual teachers have decided
on their own
carters such as charley since they did
moving on to that if you've set up a
business
model throughout the world each time you
that particular teacher does a blackbird
test
through the different ranks they send
the money back to tokyo
and we're talking about hundreds of
thousands throughout the world
each year of people going
first down all the way up to seventh
then
eight down even nowadays
in the early days no non-japanese
ever got high ranking to my knowledge
they did get to fifth down and slowly
it's
crept up but in in the last
number of years okay i'd like to
continue this
uh in the next film and but i hope
you're finding
the small points of interest they're all
what i've
either assumed myself or been told by
cytosensei
thank you please subscribe to my
youtube channel so the numbers
can get up and then i know that you're
in finding it of interest
thank you for your time